So what happened at Unite the Right 2?
A massive police presence escorted a handful
of white supremacists
through a Metro Station in Virginia.
Cameras were everywhere.
One guy was arrested for spitting on a Virginia
State police officer.
That was it right? That's it, go home.
That's it?
After a short ride to D.C.,
a few Nazis actually showed their faces in
public.
A few hundred anti-fascists hid theirs.
Thousands of counter protestors from diverse
backgrounds
rallied, chanted, and marched in the streets.
Donald Trump, you can't hide.
We charge you with genocide.
Racist cops, you can't hide.
Ain't no power like the power of the people
'cause the power of the people don't stop.
Some groups marched better than others.
Cameras were everywhere, some guy burned a
Nazi / Confederate flag hybrid
and this guy dressed up as Indiana Jones because Nazis.
As for the Right Wing protest, I have no idea
what they said
because they were completely drowned out by
loud boos and Game of Thrones references.
Shame! Shame! Shame! Shame!
As the rain fell on Lafayette Square the crowds
began to disperse.
Most counter protesters never ever saw anyone
from the far right at the rally.
I saw a few of them on their way out, it was
like a handful of people, that was it.
They have a basic right to protest, we have
a right to protest,
so we show up with more numbers.
They can't put on a showing like they think
they can.
I think that they are far outnumbered by the
American people.
They're movement is basically just incredibly
weak and should stop, just stop being Nazis.